[Musique]
caillaud quotas d'eau sort tout juste de
son emploi de vendeuse la nuit tombée
c'est souvent le cas épuisé après une
longue journée
cet appartement il a fallu des mois
avant de le trouver
c'est exigus c'est tout ce qui peut se
permettre avec son mari yasushi qui est
graphiste le lot 2 vient des japonais
pour avoir un enfant il faut de l'espace
et de l'argent distille afin de stimuler
la natalité
le gouvernement promet entre autres plus
des aides financières durant les
premières années de l'enfant encore plus
de garderie et la maternelle gratuite
deux mesures pour inciter aussi
davantage de mères à retourner au
travail
dans ce japon vieillissant en manque de
main d'oeuvre
mais comme bien des couples et ados
trouvent que ces mesures ne suffisent
pas il rappelle que plus l'enfant
grandit plus l'école et les activités
parascolaires coûte cher dans le bonheur
locaux dont je connais il voit mal
comment il pourrait se payer tout cela
enfin que pigistes sont revenus et
instable sans compter que l'avenir
l'inquiète l'économie du pays n'est pas
au beau fixe
quand on est encore en cours quand
j'étais plus jeune je n'imaginais pas
que ce serait si dur j'étais peut-être
naïve je pensais qu avoir un enfant
était facile
la réalité n'est jamais facile
est ce que vous pensez pouvoir avoir un
enfant jours suivants condomois desk
j'adore les enfants j'aime passer du
temps avec les enfants de nos amis mais
un enfant à nous pour l'instant je ne
sais pas peut-être un jour plus tard je
ne voudrais pas c'est nerim en rotin
dans ce cas c'est un
what should we je voudrais bien autre
grande question où trouver le temps
métro boulot dodo le surmenage et
courant au japon l'an dernier le
gouvernement de chine zhu ab a annoncé
qu'il y aurait une limite aux heures
supplémentaires pour permettre au couple
de trouver un équilibre travail famille
en voici une qui a laissé derrière elle
les contraintes de la grande ville pour
de bon eric y mourra et professeur en
éducation physique
ici elle peut se donner pleinement son
sport et elle s'est trouvé un emploi
dans une boutique de sur le réveil pour
nous laisser refaire il ya tout ce qu'on
veut ici la plage toujours des vagues et
les gens sont très sympas toujours
souriant c'est attirant et sinon mieux
[Musique]
et c'est aussi inspirant c'est notamment
les enfants ont l'air heureux ici c'est
un endroit idéal pour élever des enfants
chino mia est l'endroit où le sur va
effectuer ses débuts olympiques en 2020
la municipalité misé là dessus pour
attirer des jeunes familles pour se
revitaliser et nouveaux venus ont permis
de stabiliser la population selon les
autorités gracia quand je suis arrivé il
n'y avait que trois grandes familles ici
son mari est mort il ya quatre ans ses
filles elle est partie vivre en ville
puis anodine corée du nord de rio oui
dit-elle j'entends bien parler des
surfeurs qui viennent s'installer ici
mais elle ajoute qu'elle ne les voit pas
défilé danses et chants pour contrôler
gaza nous est devant nous les
agriculteurs
il ne reste que des vieux et jeunes sont
tous partis travailler dans les bureaux
a démontré m
l'agriculture est l'un des domaines où
il manque cruellement de main d'oeuvre
au japon davantage de travailleurs
étrangers devraient commencer à arriver
cette année en vertu d'un projet de loi
tout juste approuvé par le gouvernement
de chine zoabi quant à les voir
débarquer ici des millions d étrangers
on ne connaît pas leur langue non ce
n'est pas aux finalistes à la série glee
cette réticence chez une partie des
japonais voire la peur des étrangers la
crainte d'une arrivée massive empêche
des autorités d'ouvrir plus grand les
portes de l'archipel
faute de 109 que ce soit par les
naissances ou par l'immigration
ce pays vieillissant va droit dans le
mur